[Music]
foreign
[Music]
no no that's not Kim Kardashian and her
ex Kanye West look a little closer and
you'll see that's Kim and her
nine-year-old daughter North rocking
special effects makeup to make her look
a whole lot like her dad I'm just
extremely happy can you tell by my face
the clip set to yay's track Bound 2 was
posted to Kim and North's joint Tick
Tock account on Thursday
foreign
[Music]
that's northie doing her best Kanye
rocking a black beanie and an oversized
hoodie along with a Fogo tee and brows
just like the wrappers I don't know how
you're gonna top that and Kim she poses
it up with her daughter who is the
spitting image of her ex
[Music]
of course Kim famously appeared in the
2013 video for Bound 2 in nothing but
her birthday suit
nobody
uh-huh honey North's makeup skills are
seriously next level but this isn't the
first time she's tackled a makeover on
the app her new favorite thing ever is
doing makeovers and no one can see until
the final look is done last month North
dressed her little sister Chicago up
like herself taking her from Batgirl
Chic to this fit shades of black tea
shorts slides and a crossbody bag
[Music]
and back in November North gave her mom
a grinch makeover just in time for the
holidays or a mean one
Mr Grinch she really isn't she Beauty
and she loves a little bit of makeup
nice kid and before all that North gave
Kim the minion treatment
[Music]
clearly it's no secret that North loves
to get creative with makeup in fact back
in 2018 Kim told E.T that her daughter
was already getting into her kkw beauty
products I was getting ready today and
she was a little too quiet and I look
over and she's like destroying the
palette and has
just blue eyeshadow all over her entire
face she loves a before and after I
actually had to put her on our PR list
and get her her own set of makeup
because she destroys all of mine when
she sees it and then I can't use it for
myself so she she definitely loves
makeup so whether it's a grinch
transformation a minions makeover or
Kanye special effects makeup we're here
for all North's before and afters
[Music]
foreign
[Music]